when a terrorist mastermind kidnaps the
president and brings a country to its
knees there's only one Marvel franchise
that Disney can afford to call I wish
actually just this guy no really just
the guy not even the suit Tony Stark is
regular man in Iron Man 3 prepare for an
Iron Man movie with hardly any Iron Man
in it and no ac/dc either suit up with
billionaire Tony Stark as he doesn't
suit up in a summer blockbuster that for
no reason at all takes place on
Christmas and see him like you've never
wanted to see him before insecure I'm a
piping hot mess
anxious check the heart check time check
that mr. brain and paralyzed with fear
come on with regular man sidelined by
the whispers of children it's up to his
latest creation to save the day
remote control man this is a new level
of blame you've seen the Iron Man armor
hold its own against Thor the God of
Thunder
now after dozens of upgrades it runs out
of batteries time to sleep out
constantly malfunctions falls apart
falls apart again falls apart again
falls apart again butter and takes its
sweet time to assemble that five four
three come on two five
seriously The Avengers Assemble faster
than this but remote control man's not
alone
Tony spent his downtime building all
kinds of robots that break faster that
bad cosplay like forearms man choking
hazard man and crane steadying
juggernaut ban Tony and his crappy suits
must pull together to face his greatest
foe since alcoholism
the Mandarin you'll never see me coming
in a timely update of the character
Osama bin Kingsley plays the brilliant
terrorist who manipulates the entire
country into doing his bidding
my name is Trevor Trevor Slattery wait
what Oh
octo meandering sees no reason no you
can't do that they were doing such a
good job then they turned him into a
punchline
this is Iron Man's arch-nemesis this
isn't just ignoring the comics this is
dropping their pants and wiping their
butt with him what bad guys do they even
replace him with I am the manta ray oh
come on
instead we get aldrich killian and ex
nerd out for revenge after Tony skipped
a meeting one time and his nameless
henchman with a confusing grab bag of
fire powers like Chloe
getting hot exploding super-strength
regrowing lives
flameproof clothes and shooting fire out
of their mouths they really just made it
up as they went along witness the least
thought-out sequence of the Iron Man
trilogy as Tony Stark gives his personal
address to a terrorist 10 880 now
then goes home and puts on his only
unfinished Iron Man suit let someone
walk through his front door doesn't see
the missile heading for his house until
it's on the news
still doesn't activate any kind of home
security system or any of the 40 other
remote-controlled Iron Man suits in his
basement
we'll have Jarvis call the police or
shield or an Avenger so you tell me Nick
Fury shows up for coffee and doughnuts
but not when Tony Stark might be dead so
watch as the Iron Man trilogy ends with
10 of the franchise's most disappointing
minutes where Killian loses two Gwyneth
Paltrow in yoga pads all the Iron Man
suits get blown up for no reason
and Tony has the operation that will
make him regular man forever
at least until Avengers 2 starring are
2gj Cooper Hiro Gandhi nerdy memento
Murtagh Vincent Vega and the worst extra
ever there's somebody gonna kill this
guy
the sand and not starring the Hulk Thor
Captain America Nick Fury Ryan Widow
Hawkeye Agent Coulson agent Maria Hill
Sauve or even the Galaga guy
Iron Man 3 so you heard none of it I'm
not that kind of doctor dude where were
you the whole movie hey screen junkies
want to watch me make a complete fool of
myself in public then click on our epic
movie trailer voice prank go ahead click
it there on the left oh and while you're
clicking things
how about also clicking that subscribe
button hmm I'm commander shepard and
this is my favorite store on the Citadel
suck it up buttercup
Bingle bungle dingle-dangle giggity do
you CATIA ping pong lippy Kappa touka
where's my snack bag at the end of this
day one shall stand one shall fall